[music]
>> I know that inshallah if you strive, you
will all be at least be able to reach
the level two.
That is give the reference
Arabic and English.
And I know inshallah if you strive
more than 50% of the participants here
would be able to even reach the level
one.
Inshallah.
More than 50%
inshallah.
And when I say more than 50% it can even
be 90%. 99% as well.
So you would be able to reach that level
one.
Mashallah you already gave your three
verses. Anybody else? Yes brother Atik,
you have something to say?
Yes.
Brother Kaleem, I have a question. Uh
you said the best way of learning is
Arabic and then English and Arabic and
English. Mhm. Would that be helpful for
someone like me who is uh
pretty much I have hard time reading
Arabic if I'm going to learn while
listening should I try doing the same
thing or you have some other suggestion
for me?
For brother Atiq
as he earlier said that he is unable to
read Arabic text. So would this
methodology be helpful? If you strive
inshallah if Allah's help is with you
nothing is difficult.
If you strive
and Allah's help comes to you then none
can overcome you.
There are no obstacles.
But the condition is maybe you have to
strive more.
So nothing is impossible. Nothing is
difficult.
If Allah's help is with you
and you're willing to strive.
I know it would be difficult.
It would be difficult.
At first you have to learn the Arabic
listen to the audio
learn the entire recitation and then you
learn the translation
and then you know understand this verse
and mashallah one of the good things
which Dr. Zakir Naik also made a mention
in the morning about Abdullah Yusuf
Ali's translation. The reason why we
give is that most of the times Abdullah
Yusuf Ali's translation it is Arabic and
the equivalent words used in English.
Easy to understand.
So that is one of the prime reasons why
we give you
the Abdullah Yusuf Ali's translation
because mashallah this translation
Abdullah Yusuf Ali has tried his best
to match the translation
though I don't say that 100% it is the
case but majority most of the times
though we have word-to-word translations
but that is all together different but
this translation is mashallah
incorporating that it will help you
to learn the words in different parts.
Split the words
with the Arabic.
Inshallah it would be simpler to you.
Inshallah. But yeah.
Okay, can we on the mic to brother
Yusuf?
Because Masha'Allah brother Yusuf said
that he has learned 12 verses
with the English translation.
I begin from the beginning?
Okay, just give me the references first.
Of all the 12 sets, just the reference.
Not Arabic, not English. 12 references.
Only the references.
Chapter number two, verse number 110.
Chapter number
>> the way how it has been written?
I'm sorry.
Surah Al-Baqarah, chapter number two,
verse number 110. Chapter Surah
Al-Baqarah, chapter number two, verse
>> Yes. Another rule, another principle.
While the homework of revision of
Quranic verses is being taken, any
participant, when he's asked to give the
verses,
if he makes a mistake, the other
participants would raise a hand.
Any mistake he makes, whether it be in
the reference,
whether it be in the methodology of
giving the reference, whether it be in
the Arabic, whether it be in the English
translation. If he makes a mistake, the
other participants would raise their
hand and tell me what the mistake is.
Clear? Clear to everyone?
Insha'Allah, this rule is clear?
So, next time onwards,
from now on, Insha'Allah,
any participant is asked to give the
revision, and he gives the verses,
any mistake he makes, whether it be in
the reference, whether it be in the
methodology of giving the reference,
whether it be in the Arabic or the
English translation, the other
participants are asked to pay keen
attention, and this is one of the ways
how you can learn.
One of the ways how you can learn is
paying keen attention to the person who
has already memorized. Your homework
begins right from now.
You are preparing for your homework
right from now. Yes, brother Yusuf, you
can start. Bismillah Rahman Rahim. Surah
Al-Baqarah, chapter number two, verse
number 111. Surah Al-Baqarah, chapter
number two, verse number 100 and
124. surah
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 people say that you
have made a mistake.
Uh surah al-baqarah chapter number two
verse number 110.
110, surah al-baqarah chapter number two
verse number
>> wait. Look.
So many.
And you said 85%?
This one mistake and then Okay. You want
me to count more mistakes? I'm just
asking you the reference. I don't know
how many mistakes would you make.
In the other aspects of the verses.
Ask him that.
Continue. Continue.
Surah surah al-imran chapter number
three verse number 64.
Surah al-imran chapter number three
verse number 104. Surah al-imran chapter
number three verse number 110. Uh surah
surah al-tawbah chapter number nine
verse number
verse number 24. Surah surah al-tawbah
chapter number nine verse number 33.
Surah al-nahl chapter number 16 verse
number 125. Surah
uh surah Muhammad chapter number 47
verse number 38. Surah al-fath cha-
chapter number 48 verse number 28. Surah
al-ghashiyah chapter number 100 and
88 88 verse number 21 and 22. Surah
al-asr chapter number 103 verse number
one to three.
Surah Muhammad chapter 47 verse number
38.
Surah Muhammad chapter number
wa in tatawallaw yastabdil qawman
ghayrakum wa in tatawallaw yastabdil
qawman ghayrakum.
Uh if you turn back
Allah will
replace instead of you
someone who is better. Is qawman
ghayrakum thumma la yakunu amthalakum
and they will not be like you.
Surah al-imran chapter number three
verse number 104.
Waltakun ummatun yad'una ilal khayri
1 2 3 3 people have raised their hands.
Yet.
Four four people have raised their
hands.
Brother Omar
You've done your graduation in
Islamiyat.
Four people.
Arabic.
One moment. Quran.
I'm out.
You told that it's only the reference.
But I told you the other aspects I
haven't checked.
But I'm checking you now.
Let there arise a band.
Just one hint.
It is he who has sent his messenger with
guidance and the religion of truth.
Can you give me the reference in the
Arabic?
Uh
guidance of truth and then there's a
continuation. There's two versions which
>> reference in Arabic.
Give me the reference
What's the reference, brother?
And nobody's raising their hand. It's uh
chapter Suratul uh Surah Tawbah chapter
number nine verse number uh
cha- chapter number nine verse number
33.
Uh
Surah Fatah chapter number 48 verse
number 38.
Four people.
28 28 28 sorry.
Okay. Pass on the mic to Arsh.
Arsh 90%.
Inshallah, I'll try. All the 12 sets of
verses. Yes.
While preparing the homework for this
Dawah training program
one of the queries that which I had
before
earlier we have done many that were
training programs in the school for the
IS students.
And I guess it was someone from Farik's
batch or it was Farik himself.
When we give the homework earlier we
used to just say 12 verses.
12 verses.
And there are certain
verses
or there are certain
titles you would say the different
titles or the different places in the
Quran where in the reference has more
than one verse. Like for example Surat
Al-Ghashiyah chapter number 88 verse
number 21 and 22. So there are two
verses but it is one set.
Two verses but one set.
So whenever we give the homework we
mention not verses but we say 12 sets of
verses.
Which means sometimes it may even have
three. Surat Al-Asr. So if you count it
one two three. If I say I'll give you
the homework of 12 verses
then it is actually 12 13 14 15 verses.
So you can say that I have learned 12
and I haven't learned the Surat Al-Asr
and yet you're 100% in your homework. So
to overcome that mashallah this time
this query was finally resolved.
I asked Dr. Zakir Naik and alhamdulillah
he gave the solution to it as always.
Alhamdulillah.
And he said mention 12 sets of verses.
Must sticky.
Alhamdulillah.
So 12 sets of verses
12 sets of verses. Inshallah. 90%
Inshallah. Inshallah. Inshallah.
La
ilaha illallah.
ilaha [music] illallah.
Muhammadun
rasulullah.
>> [music]
>> enter
have me
enter
>> [singing]
>> enter
think
enter
>> [music]
>> enter
Malik
Allah